let's now get into the thick of it
as we might be calling it um we are
going to now look
very very closely and i'm going to put
it up on the screen because i think that
this
we're at a point where this is really uh
the only way to do it
we are going we are going to look at
what we know and what we are waiting
on when it comes to this election now as
i said
currently we are looking at numbers of
joe biden
238 and in fact i think i might might
even have a better view of this for you
uh no i don't not necessarily let me
actually
see if i can there we go i think that's
going to be better for us
perfect right now officially the count
is 238 for joe biden 213
for donald trump now as a reminder in
the map
i had for you guys yesterday i did not
believe that joe biden was going to win
florida i did not believe that joe biden
was going to win
georgia i did not believe joe biden was
going to win ohio and in fact i
even had arizona for donald trump
so relative to my map from yesterday
looking only at things that have been
called
joe biden is actually doing better than
i had everything that has been called
has been called as i predicted other
than arizona
which i had for trump and has gone to
joe biden
now the areas of concern
joe biden right now is 32
electoral votes shy of the 270 that he
needs
georgia has not yet been called but i
never believed georgia was going to go
for biden
i believe it will eventually go for
donald trump north carolina
is our first trouble spot i believed
carol
north carolina would go biden right now
with 94
reporting donald trump is ahead by 1.4
now if you were on my live stream late
last night
you might notice that these numbers are
identical to the ones that we had last
night
we don't exactly know what's going on in
north carolina different states are
starting to count
absentee ballots in different ways on
different cycles
but the numbers have not moved in north
carolina there is certainly the
expectation that there
are some strong biden areas left to be
counted
but we do not know now i will get to the
math implications momentarily
pennsylvania is an extremely important
state for us to look at
because pennsylvania is now plus 10
for donald trump but you will notice not
even two-thirds of the votes have been
counted and this is where i want to do a
deep dive with you guys before
and i hope that this is not i hope this
isn't boring to people i think this is
actually really important to do
pennsylvania is of massive importance to
joe biden
why pennsylvania's worth 20 electoral
votes
if biden gets them it puts him at 258
meaning he needs only 12
more 12 more meaning that wisconsin and
nevada would do it
or michigan would do it and certainly
north carolina would as well
why are these numbers so slow in
pennsylvania because i told you they
would be
pennsylvania doesn't start counting
mail-in ballots until
all voting has stopped
and if we go and look at the new york
times and zoom into pennsylvania
this is where the devil is really in the
details
if you look at for example philadelphia
county which contains
the city of philadelphia
you see that only about half the votes
have been counted there
joe biden continues to lead basically
three to one
it's about 75 25 even better actually in
philadelphia county for joe biden
only half of the votes have been counted
that
alone if you do just some very very
basic math
is potentially a hundreds of thousands
of
vote advantage for joe biden the numbers
there could close
half of the gap that currently exists
you then look at pittsburgh
pittsburgh which has counted 70 percent
joe biden is up by nine there that could
potentially close the gap
again by 70 000
votes theoretically allentown
has now gone towards donald trump by a
little bit
but there is a real reason to think that
the outstanding
mail-in ballots in allentown in the
allentown area which is lehigh county
could be very helpful to joe biden so
when we look at the general number and
this is not me blowing smoke
it's just an assessment of what we know
and what we expect
when you look at the numbers in
pennsylvania and you see wow
64 reporting trump is up
10. that seems impossible but then as
you realize
how much there is left to count and you
realize that a lot of those small rural
trump counties are at 100 percent
reporting
and a lot of these dense democratic
parts
are at 50 60 70 percent with
biden's margin being huge all we can do
is count the ballots we'll know
eventually the results
we will know so let's wait on that a few
other
spots to look at wisconsin
wisconsin has now flipped in favor of
joe biden
all of last night wisconsin was read as
they were at 10
15 20 25 30 even close to 50 percent
reporting
wisconsin was in the donald trump column
and
those of us who knew about the red
mirage scenario
and understood how wisconsin counts we
expected it would become
close when i went to bed it was red when
i woke up it was blue it has not yet
been called it is a small
margin as of this moment joe biden is up
21 000 votes in wisconsin
the reports from people who know
wisconsin remember
we we want to be careful and precise the
reports from folks who know wisconsin
are that the areas left to count with
mail-in ballots
are democratic leading areas if i were
looking at this
my expectation would be biden ultimately
is going to get
wisconsin and then lastly michigan
michigan
also 18 000 votes right now
separating the two candidates with joe
biden ahead
we were seeing panic yesterday but we
were also hearing
from michigan experts who said look at
what's in and look at what's outstanding
this is going to trend towards joe biden
and it has gone
indeed now slightly for joe biden now by
the time you listen to this
maybe joe biden will have won there's
the idea michigan will be called today
or tomorrow
maybe donald trump will have taken over
and then lastly
nevada nevada has 67
reporting it's worth six electoral votes
joe biden slightly ahead and then
it remains with north carolina
we have that same lead of 1.4
as of right now for donald trump and
questions about what is outstanding
there
so when we go to the map and we start
looking at
scenarios again even though georgia has
not been called for
trump i believe he gets it let's now
look at this scenario and also
alaska has not been called for trump but
i believe he gets it that would put us
at 238 to 232
in favor of joe biden okay so
what now what now is and let me even
adjust this so that we can get
uh i think i want i want the best we
don't usually do it this way but it's
just so important
that i do it because we are looking at
these election results live i want to
have everything on screen for you
um we have a situation where let's
imagine for a second that north carolina
stays with trump
okay that wouldn't be good but i want
everybody
to understand that if trump gets north
carolina
and even gets pennsylvania if joe biden
can just hold his leads
in nevada wisconsin and michigan
he wins and if he were to get the
nebraska second district
that would be 271 biden 267 repub
trump and i'll even change these to say
biden and trump i am not
trying to give you unrealistic scenarios
i am merely telling you
biden has a path without pennsylvania
and without north carolina if he were to
get
uh not north carolina but pennsylvania
all of a sudden you can take nevada off
the table and biden still wins
you can even take um you can't take
michigan off the table and that's an
error well
you could take michigan off the table if
biden gets nevada
or if he gets michigan you could take
wisconsin and nevada off the table and
biden still wins
so my point here to you is what as we
look at these numbers my point
is this was never going to be the
blowout
that 538 said it would this is why my
map
was very conservative all along
when i was telling people imagine that
your state is 50 50 and people would
email me saying david
you're gaslighting people you're making
people think it's closer than it is so
that they vote
no i'm saying we don't really know
how close some of these states are with
absentee ballots and all of these
potential factors all we know is we have
the opportunity to vote and we should
and now indeed it is going to be
much closer to my map than anything we
got from any of these modelers
so we have to just go through the
process
and understand biden can win without
pennsylvania or north carolina
if he holds his leads in nevada
michigan and wisconsin he doesn't
actually
need north carolina or pennsylvania if
biden gets
north carolina or pennsylvania
pennsylvania being more likely
those results start to look
significantly better
other things that i wanted to look at i
guess the only other thing to look at
here
would be in terms
of the presidency just looking at the
popular vote is one thing i would look
at the popular vote right now
is almost 69 million votes for joseph r
biden jr
and more than 66 million votes for
donald trump so
again joe biden by the time it's done
will have easily won the popular vote
record vote
by the way for uh donald trump added
about three million votes and we're
going to talk about that a little bit
later that is really really important
but that is where we are right now so is
it time to panic it's definitely time
for concern
but joe biden has two completely
separate paths to victory
one which includes pennsylvania and or
north carolina
less likely north carolina and one which
doesn't require either of them which
goes through wisconsin
michigan and nevada count every ballot
don't get ahead of ourselves we will be
here with you
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at deepakman
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks s h masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and
other protective gear for covid 19 and
they're giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin has a
convenient
adjustable strap and it features a
disposable
five layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to health care institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over a hundred and
fifty dollars you can get there by going
to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save twenty percent on
everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david